police are growing increasingly
concerned about a situation that's going
on in our schools 8 news now is learned
wednesday someone called 9-1-1 sent a
text about a gun at southeast career
technical academy police of course
responded so it turned out the
information someone had that a gun was
on campus was fake so was the call for
help it's called swatting when someone
makes a false call to 9-1-1 or another
person about a threat big enough to get
a large presence response to come to a
location kate houston join us now after
talking to police about the impact and
kate the consequences of swatting yes
well this is a problem for law
enforcement really across the nation now
you can be charged with seeking a false
9-1-1 call you can also be charged with
making a terroristic threat and bottom
line law enforcement say it's not a joke
swatting has gained national attention
for leading to innocent deaths and long
jail sentences there have been some very
results of this lieutenant brian zink
with ccsd pd says they've already dealt
with swatting at a few schools across
the valley depending on the type of call
and how fast we can authenticate it it
may take minutes or may take hours to
make sure that it is a fake call and not
true at all in addition to taking police
officers away from legitimate
emergencies it can also cause extreme
emotional distress for families involved
because of cell phones and social media
misinformation like this spreads very
quickly because you know we know that
there are kids inside the school that as
soon as the lockdown is initiated they
start texting their parents nine control
un channel articles zinc says they don't
stop investigating either using assets
from the federal government and other
agencies we look for certain keywords
that are mentioned that have been
mentioned in past swatting
investigations that we've done or
certain phone numbers or area codes or
location where the phone call does come
from now police are encouraging parents
to sit down with their kids and talk
about the impact this could have on
their lives it seems like it's funny
it's just a joke it's not serious but it
is very serious and it can have dire
consequences on your future
at this time school district police and
metro are investigating who made the
call and sent that text message
currently there are no federal or state
laws against swatting in 2019 the
anti-swatting act was introduced to
congress to increase those penalties but
it has remained in review back to you
brian